tout le monde corps du film où elle joue
et c'est pour ça qu'elle est dans tout
le monde en parle c'est marion cotillard
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non ça va être une star là après les
deux taxis la ja 7 millions de gens qui
sont allés voir le taxi 2 donc ce film
va finir à 12 millions d'entrées et il
va être le plus gros score du cinéma
français ever voilà vous connaissez tous
les deux non non non marion cotillard
richard anconina
je ne pouvais pas dire quand même c'est
une émission être aussi royalement
mais laëtitia juste avant maintenant il
ya marion jédir je connais son travail
ouais bien sûr formidable film vous
connaissez laurent gerra bonjour alors
vous vos parents était comédien en fait
on parlait tout à l'heure de vocation je
disais que richard anconina avait
découvert sa vocation à l'âge de 20 ans
au départ vous habitiez alfortville
c'est ça non c'est ça ouais dans une
ambiance assez cosmopolite d'ailleurs à
s'y voit arriver des vietnamiens des
kurdes des algériens des les chiliens ne
vous étiez habitués dix ans à vivre avec
tous ces gens là puis un jour vos
parents que vous aviez 11 ans sont
partis habiter dans la beauce et vous et
sympathiser avec une marocaine et on
vous en a voulu énormément dans cette
région où le front national est très
implanté en faisant n'a voulu et un jeu
de connard en particulier ouais c'était
pas une raison
et vous en choper sous un escalier
ils vous ont vidé un litre d'eau de
cologne sur la tête
ouais pour vous désinfecter et après
j'ai pu parler à personne d'être fair
mairie après ouais j'ai oui j'ai ça m'a
un peu ça m'a un peu choqué ouais on
peut le dire mais c'était surtout elle
s'était surtout les propos qu'ils
étaient tenus pendant qu'ils m'ont
des infectés comme moi disait qu'était
qui était super super violent et que moi
je connaissais pas vraiment en tout cas
le racisme
j'ai découvert le racisme à cette
occasion j'ai dû plus là j'ai découvert
vraiment le racisme en quittant en
quittant la cité je me suis remémoré
après des propos qui ont été tenus
pendant que j'étais non non non dans cet
immeuble qui qui qui maurer fait
percuter que j'avais déjà décelé des
petits trucs de racisme quelque part
mais c'est vraiment là que j'ai je me
suis pris en pleine gueule
ouais en fait le théâtre si vous l'aviez
découvert bien avant donc parce que
comme aux parents était comédien visite
y visionner dans les coulisses quand
elle avait besoin d'un bébé on nous
prenait vraiment alors vous
contrairement à richard je dirais un
enfant de la balle
oudin 6 ans vous avez fait deux
téléfilms à 5 ans vous étiez déjà sur
les planches avec votre mère qui jouait
dans une pièce mise en scène par
mesguich l'été vous allez avignon et vos
parents enfin j'ai été nourri de nourrir
théâtre nourrit des planches votre mère
vous disais un truc sur l'expérience qui
est assez marrant j'ai noté c'est on
peut parler durant des années de la
neige à un africain c'est seulement
quand il verra le groenland qui
connaîtra la réalité donc en fait elle
vous a appris beaucoup de choses mais
c'est en vous frottons au cinéma que oui
c'est une phrase qu'est quelle masse
c'est pas une phrase à elle
c'est une phrase d'un maître indien et
indiens nous change tout et voilà ces
voix là des petites phrases qui qui
m'aide à vivre
il vous dit j'ai aussi appris avec mes
paroles réalisme je sais ce que c'est de
manger des patates un jour et du caviar
le lendemain dont vous avez été très
jeunes habitués à tout ça je mangeais
pas de caviar
non vous êtes heureuse avec combles et
non oui taxi de ça marche il ya un an et
demi vous avez rencontré le prince
charmant
ça marche toujours avec lui sarah avec
la peintre je vais pas dire son nom
rassurez-vous les comédiens réalisateurs
sans nom commence par un alors je dirais
pas j'ai pas comme ça moi j'ai
extrêmement bien bah oui oui mais en
parlant de ce que vous vivez avec lui on
va vous allez m'expliquer ce que je
comprends bien vous dit l'amour ça rend
la peau plus douce
j'ai pas dit plus justement la peau
douce mais ça vous avez raison mais ça
roule un peu douce pas moi je moi quand
je fais l'amour après j'ai la peau plus
douce assez marrant ça ça vous fait ça
mais ça vous le fait savoir à madame
elle est d'accord avec moi mais d'accord
donc ça vous fait salement la peau que
juste après avoir fait l'amour
non ça c'est un truc spécifiques aux
femmes je sais pas moi j'ai toujours
toujours eu la police pareil mais vous
vous en déduisez 2
je ne sais pas non non c'est c'est comme
on dit chimiques
c'est plus boîte aussi et surtout oui
mais après la douche alors vite ici dans
tous les cas je viens d'avoir la peau
vachement douce la ba écoute et oui ça
va ouais j'ai cru que j'avais l'air
devant la peau super douce qu'elle
saluait alors
vous avez un point commun avec laurent
gerra pendant la pause au juste mathilde
seigner à la peau très douce non c'est
que le vous dit le mariage ça me branche
pas pour moi c'est poussiéreux bien
l'avouer c'est marrant c'est que comme
vous quoi je dis pas que ces poussières
mort mais alex est vrai que ça me touche
pas ouais
et puis rsa la branche pas en plus c'est
la cérémonie moi qui m'en mais on va
embrasser les vieilles tentes avec des
moustaches par l'épatante et non
maintenant mais des détentes d'état des
tatas des mois écouter je connais
françois saignés d'ambra il va refaire
la maison ça va être bien non se
branchent pas non plus le mariage pour
écouter je crois que je vais être obligé
de vous faire une interview psy
[Musique]
c'est formidable c'est derrière bissau
et caf a expliqué on ne bouge pas
pendant le jingle ça c'est formidable
c'est énorme
dites-moi interruption donc on va faire
un petit tour de votre psychisme
d'accord est ce que vous êtes parano ça
m'arrive dans quelle occasion mais j'ai
droit à des jockeys ou pas abattant des
si vous avez si vous prenez des jokers
c'est anconina et géra qui répondent à
votre place non je suis parano quand je
suis pas très bien dans ma peau et quand
préféré répondre vous finalement m s'ils
arrêtent de fumer trop de cigarettes
c'est dégueulasse il ya deux mois j'ai
déjà arrêté vous avez arrêté à moitié
moitié et adorable est ce que vous êtes
schizo pas du tout enfin ça peut non non
ça va ce côté là ça va est ce que vous
êtes maso non enfin envers moi même ça
peut m'arriver aussi vous fait du mal je
peux me faire du mal à moi mais moi ce
que vous aimez quand vous fasse du mal
non
s'il vous plaît pas est-ce que vous êtes
sado
c'est un peu près normale non je ne vais
pas faire ma non ça me plait pas bien
jusque là ça va si vous êtes sado maso
ça rend la proue tous c'est bien connu
non moi je préfère qu'elles soient
douces en douceur donc j'ai pas du dos à
dos mais pas pour la violence
est ce que vous êtes géronto je sais pas
ce que c'est geron tous et des filles
qui aiment bien les vieux vieux ouais je
me doutais bien vieux je sais pas ce que
c'est exactement vieux non plus je comme
moi quoi moi je ne trouve pas vieux par
exercer non mes vieux genre vieux à
partir de 60 70 non je suis pas
gérontologie d'accord mais jusqu'à quel
âge vous êtes jusqu'à quel âge et
agiront temps à partir de quel âge je ne
sais pas 50
ça va encore est ce que vous êtes porno
je pas vous aimez regarder des cas c'est
des machins dans ce sens là pas du tout
pas du tout non je suis pas du tout
porno moi j'aime pas ça non je peux être
porno mais pas à pas vous regardez
jamais de films pornos par exemple
jamais bon franchement ça me vous feriez
retrouve pas se taper non il est assez
normal comme fille a assez vous ne
regardez jamais non plus vous riche à
moi je regarde pas parce que le cas je
m'en sert presque jamais pfoten un quart
d'heure se ressent ça pendant huit jours
c'est vrai foot justice parce que c'est
quand même qu'il fallait un quart
d'heure
et vous jamais va faire participer mois
ah ouais nous et que le voir à la télé
tu goûtes c'est marrant mais moi je
préfère participer
ouais vas faire un tract est ce que vous
êtes meadow celle inverse de géronto je
dis ça pour vous inviter les spectateurs
qui n'ont pas l'habitude de tous ces
mots paix doan ont pedu non plus vous
êtes zoo vous êtes travelo vous a déjà
tenté à 10 ans vous êtes vachement
sérieuses comme fille
vous savez ces trucs normal que je suis
la tournée c'est les destinations les
plus communes dépenses et la cbc le top
15 des déviations des français ça là je
préfère normal que sérieuse bon excuse
et de disco ah ouais
non
[Musique]
je vous demande de vous arrêter je vous
demande de vous arrêter
on allume bien aimable les corrections
de ne rien rater de l'inaptitude abonnez
vous mettez un pouce bleus